well first to the spiritual question
which is an interesting question to me
everyone
casts the psychedelic experience in
terms of being a subcategory of the
spiritual quest I'm not exactly sure
about that I've taken lots of
psychedelics over nearly 30 years now
and you know I have a marriage
dissolving I have people who will tell
you I'm a terrible person to negotiate a
contract with I feel myself to be a
moral Paragon of nothing and and I'm not
sure it has anything to do with the
spiritual quest it seems to me true
spirituality is a very here-and-now
matter one should visit the sick and
imprisoned clothe the naked bury the
dead care for orphans feed the hungry
that's what the spiritual life is about
it's very down-to-earth straightforward
I'm very puzzled and and I put more than
psychedelics in this in this category
what like mantras young trees practices
do these things really ameliorate the
suffering of the human condition
they may be good for something the
question is what perhaps indirectly the
psychedelic synergize the spiritual life
because they just show you that life is
to be taken seriously and there is a
great deal of it to be assimilated but
in terms of suggesting that you are a
more spiritually advanced person if you
take psychedelics I don't really see any
evidence for that I
do you think that that you cannot take
psychedelics without losing a portion of
your ego because it will it's too hard
for the egomaniac
to take psychedelics the egoist will
turn away from it we'll have such bad
trips that they will put it down I think
this is an interesting question
this question of you know like the
question I asked myself here we are we
are psychedelic people presumably by
some high percentage are we in any way
morally superior to people who don't
take psychedelics maybe we're a little
bit gentler and more open-minded but
probably in any mud-wrestling situation
we can be just as down and dirty as the
next person to some degree so I I see it
more as that's why I don't think of
myself as a guru I think of myself as an
explorer of the geography the purposes
of which are probably multiple in other
words I suppose we can use psychedelics
to shape personalities and brainwash
people and control them and I suppose we
can use it to lead people to make peace
with death mortality their own
limitations it seems to me it's a
morally neutral dimension and and it can
be used for good or ill and maybe
slightly edging toward the good because
it's very hard for egomaniacs to do
anything with this stuff I asked in the
Amazon I asked the mushroom at one point
because I could see that we were going
to carry it back
to the world in some form I said can't
this be perverted can't it be misused
and it said only the only the good can
come near this
well may be good doesn't mean exactly
what we think it means you know isn't it
kind of piety worn on your cup it's it's
something else it's a sincere wish to
understand that's the motivation that
the psychedelic swirled turbocharged
[Music]